[Music]
hi good afternoon I'm Robert I'm a big
data specialist based out of Amsterdam
and here today together with a shock
he's from the Bay Area custom engineer
working in the Bay Area so we're gonna
take you today for migrating data
warehouses if you have like a question
that really can't wait into the end just
put up your hand there's gonna be quite
we're going to do this in three sections
so the first 10-15 minutes we're going
to go through a little bit of the
reasoning why then we can look at some
reference architectures after we've done
that we will move on to a demo for about
20 minutes and actually look at some of
the work involved and then we'll come on
to the more like the let's say the
logistics of it so we can go for the
technology but after that what does it
actually look like to actually get all
the parties involved actually committed
and working towards the goal of this
data warehouse migration so to start
this off let's have a little think about
a data warehouse and what it actually is
so often when we're talking about data
warehouses when I'm working with
customers and I should say previous to
joining Google myself I was a customer I
worked for a company as a lead data
engineer and I moved to data warehouse
to a bigquery so I have some hands-on
experience with the stuff as well and
when we were doing that you know often
when I was talking to some of the people
in the business you know the use case
that was presented was the data
warehouse well the data warehouse isn't
a use case it's a it's something that
enables use cases so it's the underlying
platform and that was really key to kind
of get in everyone's like minds to say
look you know there's a reason why we're
doing this
and let's understand what that reason is
because then we can actually think about
what we want to do because you know
there might be some stuff we want to
migrate there might be some workloads
that we no longer want to take with us
but all of the use cases we're trying to
fill now we try to split this up into
four different types of use case I'm
going to walk through them now so here
they all have operational reporting ad
hoc reporting ad hoc analysis and
operationalized insight so I take
through one by one so the first one
operational reporting this is your you
know the common typical dash
boarding area so you know I'm in the
business and I want a dashboard to
actually see you know how much inventory
do I have left how are the sales doing
this month those dashboards mean you
know the queries get built out the
dashboard gets puts in place so what are
some of the concerns that we might want
to think about if we're going to migrate
some of these workloads or what are some
of the concerns are typically associated
with this particular use case well one
is obviously data quality if the data
quality is not good you know those
numbers aren't good data timeliness
that's a big thing I mean often when
you're working on premise with your data
warehouse team especially if you're
coming from let's say more legacy setup
there's a lot of batch processes that
run at night if one of those batch
processes fails then the question is is
everything going to be there in time to
get the numbers out the next day I hit
that question so many times in the past
and then reliability which you know it
obviously comes in to the other two as
well but if you don't have good
reliability with your system then you're
trying to you know the other two are
very difficult to deliver on let's say
so next one is ad hoc reporting so
typically with the operational reporting
you know that is the thing that everyone
says I want those numbers I want those
dashboards available if they're not
there you probably have some you know
some measurements and metrics around
there some s ellos that you're trying to
say like these dashboards are going to
be ready ups you know available for
everyone to use the ad hoc reporting
sometimes suffers because it's resource
bound I mean you haven't certain number
of resources are you using to do all
your processing and then when it comes
to the actual ad hoc reporting piece you
know there are people that have ideas
they want to try and start looking at
things they're using visualization tools
and this kind of stuff and yeah they
essentially what they need is like more
data they need visualization tools and
they need access to historical data so
all of this requires like we have enough
storage to store the data we have enough
capacity to run those kind of processing
and we can support all the different
types of tools that they want to use so
the next one is ad hoc analysis this is
a kind of the data science there's
cystic alaria where people are actually
going in there they're trying to work
out you know what's what's this
trend what's his thing that I'm looking
at why have I got why ever got some
country for example as underperforming
in sells you know it's been doing well
all the time and now some its
underperforming what caused that and
again what we need here is you know
strong tools to be able to do this again
capacity comes up if you don't have the
capacity then these these types of
questions and sometimes get put in
second place because the other things
have been prioritized and the last one
operational insight this is
operationalized inside she sayin there's
gonna be a tongue twister this is really
where everyone wants to be this is the
place where essentially you've done all
this analysis work and you're using it
to predict the future
so you're using it to work out for
example here you know I'm I'm trying to
work out how much fuel I need or how
much does your purchase for the next
quarter I'm using these numbers to
actually drive those decisions this is a
decision-making space again some of the
challenges in this area predictive
capabilities like what kind of tools
what kind of frameworks do you want to
support diverse data sources again dates
coming from all different places some of
it can be stored easily in the data
warehouse some of this in the data lake
or you know maybe not even available and
again having enough capacity to run this
stuff so I'm gonna make some very gross
generalizations but what we see when
we're looking at working with customers
and again these are generalizations so
they might not be specific to you and
that some of the stuff that we see for
example is that a lot of work is being
done and a lot of people start from the
operational reporting side and they want
to move to that operationalized insight
but there's a lot of stuff that has to
be done to get them there and they don't
want to sacrifice all the the work that
they've done to have the operational
reporting in place so if we're going to
migrate the data way up dated data
warehouse you know we could say oh great
now we can do this opera we can run some
machine learning models and we can take
that output and we can make it available
so we can do some kind of recommendation
system for example but if they can't
like support the reports and the - balls
that they've been relying on then
they're like well first we need to solve
that that's what we see coming you know
time and game and we see often you know
a lot of customers when they're working
with their stuff you know on premise
they struggle for resources and infinite
that there's a finite number of
resources that they have and those
resources are you know yeah there's a
lot of claim on those resources so you
know there's a good reason for them to
me to the cloud because we can you know
give them more and more resources to use
we don't have those same constraints but
yeah hopefully that gives some
indication the reasons why we would do
this so is another kind of
generalization this is the kind of
movement we see we see people starting
with operational reporting with ad hoc
reporting and moving up instead of
operation eyes in sight and of course a
lot of that operational insight is based
off that ad hoc analysis as well you
know building out those machine learning
models or other prediction models to
actually take you to that place where
you can start putting this into some
kind of process to actually make
decisions so I mean obviously no slide
deck is complete without Maslow's
pyramid so here's here's a best attempt
at something very colorful what we
basically got here is like if you look
at each level this is to get to that top
piece this is the kind of stuff that is
built on so we've got data quality data
timeliness right there the bottom we've
got the the capacity and the talling you
need all of these things to be able to
fulfill your different use cases so this
is where your platform should be
providing okay so why do why do people
well what if folks actually consider
migrating their data warehouse in there
in the first place
well I mean obviously I've just been
through some of them but just to kind of
recap you know cost of infrastructure
not having enough resources another one
that we see is like there are specific
skill set so you need to run some of
these systems so for example let's say
you're running hive on Hadoop you know
you might have a whole team that's
actually required just to support that
hive installation and that might not be
core to their business
so you're thinking hang on like I don't
mind having one or two people doing this
but having a whole team I could have
that team doing something else so these
are things to think about
and you know some of the stuff that we
that the kind of limits there as well as
things like upgrade so I'm sure some of
you went to the data proc talked
yesterday and you would have seen for
example you know you can it's very easy
in the cloud to run different versions
of Hadoop whereas when you're on premise
and you need to update because you're
missing some capability you know that
might mean shutting off the cluster
actually performing the update and if it
doesn't go well rolling back so you have
this kind of you know this game that you
have to play to actually give that
capability that you're trying to offer
to your end users and concurrency often
suffers as well a lot of these systems
have the kind of performance that you're
required to actually run the query but
when it comes to many users asking you
no questions at the same time there is
some trade-off and concurrency there so
Google clouds data warehouse I'm just
going to take a sip of water that's
always good for YouTube so Google clouds
data warehouse well
bigquery as you know that's why you're
here obviously I probably don't need to
tell you any of these things because
you've probably already been looking at
bigquery and you're thinking
yeah that's great I know bigquery but
just for anyone that hasn't you know
seen it these are some of the things
that we call out on bigquery for the
reasons why customers are going to move
later I look at some of the newer
features that be mentioned today but
some of the important ones here and I
think like the most crucial when you're
migrating a data warehouse it's like you
know can I use the skills I already have
so standard sequel that's a hugely
important one you know can it cope with
the amount of data and the concurrency
that I need to actually you know get the
benefits everyone's able to perform
their analysis I can run all these
different types of reports and fur and
you know security here so the encryption
you can we have default encryption on
all of our storage you can choose to
bring your own encryption keys so for
particularly sensitive workloads you
know managing your own encryption keys
would might be a good thing for you to
be able to do that's particularly
important in something like the finance
sector was turned data and then you know
highly available manage that it's that
you don't have to focus on the operation
of bigquery you can actually focus on
using bigquery and I
creating your use cases so very
high-level architecture this is what
bigquery looks like there are there are
a number of parts but I will try and
yeah break it down so storage is
separated from compute this is common
across all of Google products
we'll see it a little bit more in a
minute in a moment that pet that pet a
bit network in between it's actually 1.3
petabytes as something like a hundred
and thirty thousand machines talking at
ten gigabits per second that's what that
essentially means is that we can have
our compute disaggregated from our
storage we can grow either one
independently we can serve multiple you
know queries from the same storage we
can you know for example if you were
trying to create your own data warehouse
using hive and park' and how do for
example you would have to make some
choices as you grow that cluster you
know there is a ratio of CPU and memory
that you attach to those disks that you
are that you're making available and you
obviously you can optimize you because
I'm gonna have bigger disks and you know
fewer CPUs or the other way around but
you still need to think about that
they're not separate here they are and
that's really possible because of the
network in between and how fast there is
other things which are very important
here is that we have on the right hand
side standard sequel so everyone can use
a language which is common to them and
on the left-hand side we support both
batch and streaming data so you can have
a table with you know like a petabyte of
data in that table and you can still be
streaming in the latest updates and you
can query over both of those in the same
query so you can have a query which is
basically running and giving you you
know the context between what's
happening now and the historical data
from running a sequel query so this is
not unique to bigquery that separation
this is across all of our products so if
you look at the bottom here these are
all the different types of storage I
have a storage session sarsen and if you
want to know more about that but the
different types of storage for exact
call a few out here so bigquery is
column of storage so Dremel was the
original white paper we
color capacitors like an evolution from
there to give you an idea storage
formats like parquet are actually based
off a dremel so a big table its key
value is column family it's really good
for random reads and writes sometimes
you might want to query that with sequel
well that's possible through bigquery
doing Federation you can also let's say
you had a data Lake and you've got Avro
file CSV files or files park' files JSON
files and you don't want to load those
yet into bigquery for some reason you
can have them available on Google Cloud
storage and you can run federated
queries over them as well so some of
them will you can do federated queries
and others you have to load for your job
but CSV Avro and JSON also pull the
federated query model so you have
different options available to here I
mean obviously if you want to get the
best native performance of bigquery then
the column of storage is obviously
suited for running acting and you know
analytical queries that's why that
storage exists but this gives you an
idea and the same data that you're
storing in bigquery maybe you need to
make available to your machine learning
algorithms for training so you'd have at
the top their cloud ml engine which can
access bigquery and actually pull from
that date storage actually go and train
this model so it's really about thinking
about which storage fits and what type
of processing fit so on the top of his
big query it's sequel on the bottom if
it's big query is column of storage on
the body if you have a random readwrite
use case you would think about something
like BigTable if you wanted to run some
federated ad hoc query so that you could
use bigquery if you wanted to have you
know the column of performance and you
would use something like data flow to
take that bigquery data that that
BigTable data story and load it into
bigquery so you get a benefit from the
high performance and if you need both
types of access so the high analytical
performance and the random readwrite
stuff use two types of storage just make
sure the pipeline's feeding that a edom
potent functional so that you can you
know reload it and have a consistent
output we will look a little bit about
that in the demo in a moment so moving
on here
this is one of our customers I'll let
you read this yourself but this is
basically wrong and we bring up the
begone like the reason for doing this
together with us is that we work on the
providing assistant managed service and
you work on your use cases the more we
can do that the more we can have a
successful partnership together but we
have our engineering focus on like
bringing capabilities and you have your
engineering focused on using those
capabilities to do cool stuff of it so
I'm going to move very quickly to the
reference architectures this first
reference architecture let me go back a
slide this is like okay I'm going to do
a migration now where do I start
so obviously you don't jump and say
right click your fingers and the
migration is done migrations are complex
this is the first setup that we like to
advocate so on the left hand side we've
basically got your current on-premise
situation this this may look like what
you're running on Prem it may not but to
give you some idea this is kind of like
you know you have your saw systems
you have some kind of ETL process which
loads of data into staging runs you know
does some transformation maybe
denormalization dimensionalize as that
data makes it available in a data
warehouse and there's a whole bunch of
reports and use cases that are taking
advantage of their data there and the
orchestration piece in the middle that's
basically allowing you to do all of that
making sure that happens every day
making sure things happen in the right
order
so in the first move that we're going to
look at in the demo in a moment it's
actually a mirroring so we will read
from the current data warehouse and our
goal will be in the first instance is to
have the same available and bigquery now
from once it's available in bigquery you
can start denormalizing some of their
data aggregating some of their data to
make it available for use cases so for
new reporting news cases we're gonna use
data studio here but there's a whole
bunch of tools out there from partners
and that you can use for the reporting
as for the eto as well what would come
on to that in a moment
so the piece that we're going to look at
here is like what do we need to do to be
able to mirror the data warehouse on to
bigquery and so kind of recap why are we
doing this we want to get results fast
we want to have the least amount of risk
to our business you know we
selling them on quite a big thing so we
don't want to say look go ahead and do
this and then once you've done it you
know like like we will see how long it
takes no let's take a route where we can
do some of this show them how good it
works for them show them what they get
out of it
you know don't put their current process
in at risk and once that works then we
can move on to the next phase and we
also get GCP adoption you know there are
many people that haven't used all the
GCP tools it may be in your business are
the developers are the analysts are the
business users and they get from this
the opportunity to start working with
those tools and importantly we can
benchmark stuff you know numbers talk so
we can actually show to any of our
stakeholders look you know we were
running these queries here before it was
taking this much or we had this kind of
concurrency we could only support this
number of users and now we can do this
so you get that from this first
architecture what's the target well I
mean we don't want to go from running
one data warehouse to running to day 2
warehouses the whole idea is to do is
migration so the target is obviously to
actually have the full data warehouse
process running on GCP and reading from
those sources now those sources might be
on GCP they might be on Prem they could
be on another cloud provider but
essentially for this particular
migration what we're looking at is
taking a data from wherever those
sources may be and doing the ETL process
doing the data warehouse process in on
Google cloud and that's what we're going
to look at in the demo so both those
stages so with that I'm going to hand
over to a shot for the demo section
thanks Rob
all right let's get into it so today
we'll look at what it takes to you know
do the migration to GCP and in this
first stage we look at the mirroring the
data warehouse to bigquery and we'll
start with the data already landed in
Google Cloud Storage so I'll be doing a
lot of back-and-forth switching because
of the slides and demo ok so what we've
done is we've taken
we are mirroring on Prem data warehouse
right so we already have the facts and
dimension data and since facts are
usually
larger in size we have to organize them
by date and let's take a look at the
fact data here so they are organized by
date and if something goes wrong or you
update your on-prem data warehouse all
you do is just you know reload the
partition right and in bigquery we are
going to store this as a partition table
and dimensions are usually small so you
don't really have to partition them and
it's okay to basically refresh all the
dimension data every day and this also
ensures that any slowly changing
dimension techniques that you've
employed would just carry over to the
data warehouse as well and this is how
the dimension data looks for the for the
demo and for the demo I am using TP CDs
data just to get a data warehouse set up
so one second yeah I need to get a hang
of switching here okay so we looked at
the data sets so what we're doing is we
are going to store we're going to stage
the data in Google Cloud Storage facts
organized by date and dimensions in just
a folder we are going to do a refresh
every day and then we're going to use
cloud composer to basically orchestrate
this workflow and materialize the table
in bigquery native format once that is
done what we'll do is we'll run some
downstream aggregation queries we can
materialize that as well and it's always
a good practice to materialize you know
aggregation queries that are frequently
used so that your reports are not laggy
right we're due to runtime calculations
and also the data is not open for
interpretation all right so let's take a
look at that okay so what we're trying
to do is we are trying to get to this
report right so this report is basically
calculating cumulative sales and returns
per sales channel and below we sing a
scatter plot of net sales by buy
different channels so how do we get them
so as I said we are using cloud composer
to basically orchestrate this workflow
so we are seeing here is on the Left we
are creating staging tables so we are
basically creating a federated bigquery
table which is pointing to a file in
Google Cloud storage and then we
materialize that into a native bigquery
table and once that is done we do the
same thing with fact tables but it may
so happen that you know you probably
have to replay a partition right because
you've updated something on Prem so you
have to replay the partition for your
fact data so what we have done is
basically we have added a boolean
variable in the airflow code to
basically just load fact data and not
dimension data so in this way you have a
repeatable idempotent process for
loading fact data and this is a code
that does just that right so all I'm
doing is so this is an airflow variable
which i've defined up here and then if
it is yes then we load dimension and
staging if it is no we just load the
dimension alright so let me just trigger
this and then I'll walk you through the
individual processes so I'm going to
trigger it for today so let's just
quickly check if the variable is set for
today it is yes 25th so I'm going to go
back and trigger the table let's look at
the tag all right so it is running so
let's just go back okay
so I spoke about external tables being
used for staging purpose and Google
Cloud Storage being the staging area
let's take a look at the definition of
those so the dimension table as I said
is refreshed daily so it's just pointing
to a location in Google Cloud Storage
without any database partitions and the
fact tables are partitioned by date and
they are in a store in a date folder so
it is today right and for materializing
those tables from the staging area into
bigquery native all we're doing is just
a simple select star into a table but
then you could obviously you know get
creative and then add your own
transformations or you know do further
DeNoble ization if needed the
aggregation query that i'm using is a
simple query that aggregates all the
sales and returns by three different
channels their sales this store web and
catalog channels and I'm just doing a
cumulative you know sales and written
just a summation on all the three up to
today let's take a look at the dag if
it's finished they're still running well
give it a minute okay so as you can see
the staging areas have been created and
then they have been materialized now we
are the stage where we are trying to
materialize fact that is done as well so
it's success now it's the last stage
where we are materializing the
aggregation query as well so once this
is done we should be able to we should
be able to see a partition in the sales
by channel table which I created for
materializing the hydration query and
this is done as well let's take a look
at the partition so I'm querying the
partition summary metadata for that
particular table and if I run this query
I should see a partition here so as you
can see so for 25 which was created just
now now if I go to the report I should
be able to see the report being updated
for today there you go
so that's demo one where we mirrored the
on-prem data warehouse to Google Cloud
Storage now let's take a look to switch
up say sorry about
okay so let's take a look at demo two
wherein we have done the cutoff right so
the end state is we are running the data
warehouse in Google Cloud storage and
you know what does it take to you know
make that functional okay so this
workflow looks quite similar to what we
had earlier but there's a significant
difference we are partitioning
dimensions as well now it's obvious why
we partition facts because they are
large and you know I've spoken about
that but why dimensions number one to
keep the whole workflow simple and easy
to maintain and we have a reproducible
and unimportant process data pipeline is
concerned and also because CDs are
cumbersome right slowly changing
dimensions are cumbersome and can get
easily complicated with this what you
can do is you're just doing a refresh of
your everyday you know dimension data
into a new partition in bigquery this
gives you by temporality
easy-to-implement by temporality you can
go back in time and look at the state of
your data at that point in time by just
querying a particular partition in
dimension so you don't have to create
complex joins or you don't have to have
complex ETL processes to maintain so
that's why we are partitioning dimension
data as well so this is part of the
functional data engineering approach
which we have taken here and the fact is
the fact data is partitioned by even
date and the dimension data is
partitioned by the processing date when
you process this okay so I'm going to
switch back here and go to my second
demo so I said that dimension and fact
are both partitioned or once you do a
cut off let's take a look at the
dimension data so it is in fact
partition by date let's take a look at
the dag that supports this whole
workflow so it's similar to the one that
we had earlier we are creating staging
tables doing a federated and creating a
federated table in bigquery for both
dimension and fact we are a material
Dimension Data so note that we are using
T PCE specification data which is in
third normal form so obviously we have
to create a fax and Dimension Data you
know when we materialized in bigquery so
this task is doing just that it is
materializing the Dimension Data once
that is done we are going to materialize
the fact data and that will be the end
of this workflow so let me just trigger
this and then walk you through the whole
process okay so that's triggered now
let's take a look at the various queries
so I said that the dimension and fact
tables are both organized by date so
this is a fact table trade it's
organized by date and let's take a look
at the company table which is a
dimension data it's also organized by
date in the staging area and the queries
that I'm using to materialize these
tables into bigquery are simple joints
so basically I'm denormalizing the data
this is for trade and I'm basically an
adjoining that with status type and
trade type and for company I'm basically
joining that with state of status type
and address right so you could actually
use any ETL process any ETL tool of your
choice to do this but in this case I'm
just using you know sequel and the
staging area being Google Cloud storage
but one thing to note is that for a
company which is a dimension table we
are now having a partitioned date which
is called a creator date here and we are
partitioning based on that date which is
the day when you run the workflow and
for trade which is a fact data we are
basically in a partitioning by the event
date which is T and ESCO DTS in this
example let's also take a look at one of
the queries that will be running after
the dag completes so in the previous
example we saw how we could create you
know we could materialize a query and
then create a report on top of it what
bigquery can also be used for ad hoc
analysis and this query is basically
calculating the 60 second simple moving
average on bid prices in a three
our period for all the securities that
just get unloaded once attack completes
let's take a look at the dag if it is
completed its running it'll be done soon
okay so the materialization of
dimensions is complete now the next
stage is basically materialization of
the fact table which is trade and once
that is done we'll run our moving
average query
it's running little it'll happen so what
I'm doing here is I'm deleting so
basically we are creating a staging
table right so the files are in Google
Cloud storage and we are creating a
federated table so obviously every day
when you run you have to point that
table to the right and a file in Google
Cloud storage so hence the first step is
to basically delete the table definition
and then recreate it with the file for
that date so that is what this stage
does so now the crates page table is
done it's a success now finally what we
are doing is we are going to run the
query that I showed earlier the
denormalization query which joins trade
table with address and shaders type and
then creates the fact table in bigquery
it should be done in few seconds here
and that's done so let's go and run our
query here for today which is a moving
average a 60 second moving average over
a three hour period for all the
Securities and there you go so it just
ran and we have all the moving air so
bigquery can be used for a log analysis
as well and that completes the
end-to-end workflow so for when you know
completely when you do a complete cutoff
now let's look at another interesting
concept in bigquery so with so far we've
seen a functional data engineering
approach where we know create no
repeatable and unimportant processes and
we basically replay the workflow and
then update the partitions right so we
don't do any DML statements but DM else
can be friendly when when used in the
right format and the right way and when
you do a DML update you update a large
chunk of data in bigquery but what if
something goes wrong so how do you
recover from it so we're gonna take a
look at that
exactly now so what I'm showing here is
a query that basically creates a trade
table that we just loaded and for a
particular customer ID 472 so let's take
a look as to what the data looks like
now let's say that I want to update this
trade table for this particular customer
for a particular security but what
instead is I just updated all the
updated the Commission column for all
the rows for that particular customer so
that's obviously an error so I realized
that I made a mistake so how do I
recover from this so there are two
options ideally the first option is go
back in time all you have to do is just
replay your workflow with you know your
partition date equals 22 in this case
right so July 22 and then you just
override the partition and then go on
from there
or you could use bigquery snapshots
right so bigquery snapshots are
automatically created and maintained for
you for seven days and then you can go
back in time and then get the state of
your table at that point in time so we
only use bigquery snapshots and DML to
recover from this error but before we do
that let's take a look at what the
status of the table is after the update
so what I did is I updated the
Commission column but you know equals to
$45 for all the rows for that particular
customer so this is how it look like
looks like let's look at the bigquery
snapshot so how it was five minutes ago
right before I did my update so as you
can see the Securities have the right
Commission values now we're going to use
that and create a temporary table which
we are going to then use and do an
update join on the trade table that we
you know erroneously updated so the
temporary table is created now I'm going
to run an update join what the temporary
table and my trade table further you
know for the partition that I just
messed up okay so that's done so what it
did is it basically updated all my
customer rows for customer equals 42
from my know bigquery snapshot the
temporary table that I just created from
it let's take a look at how the data
looks like after correction so it should
be similar to what we looked in the
Vickery snapshot and it is it is not $45
now we can just go back
and no update for the security that we
really Internet to update it's done and
then we'll just see how it looks like
once it's updated so all good so you
know no backlash yes sir right so that's
the end of the demo before I hand it off
to Robert I'm going to quickly talk
about various ways or to ingest data
into DCP so we've looked at using Google
Cloud Storage the staging area so you
can use gsutil and storage transfer
service or the data transfer service
that comes native to Google to ingest it
into GCP but there are a plethora of
partner products as well which you can
use and you might already be using these
today in your existing toolkit and it's
an easy switch to basically you know
migrate data from your on-premise
systems or your social systems into GCP
so what you Rob thank you a shock
so hopefully that kind of showed you
like how easy some of this stuff can be
I mean we saw two approaches we saw the
functional engineering approach
overwriting partitions keeping things
edan potent and repeatable and as a
shock demonstrated in the last piece if
you do have like DML statements that
you're gonna run over multiple days over
a very large table you have the big
query basically time travel
functionality for the last seven days to
actually go back and restore so that
will hopefully you know help you in some
of this work that you're going to do and
again like bigquery is like you know
it's it's the crown jaws of our data
products and it really sits in the
middle and in a huge ecosystem these are
some of the partners for the integration
there's a whole bunch of partners as
well for reporting and everything else
so it's it's really you know depending
on you know how you want to approach
this you're in good hands so let me just
for anyone that missed anything some of
the new product features you saw
throughout this demo today the new
bigquery UI you can already go and use
that so
for those of you who are saying hey the
bigquery UI looks different what's this
new thing up here this is not bigquery
that's in UI UI this morning you heard
about BQ ml so these are not things that
you can start to do once your you know
operating in bigquery we got
partitioning at the moment so you can do
partitioning on like the insertion date
or you can choose your own date column
as we saw here with two different
examples of partitioning we saw an
example that where we were actually
partitioning on a logical date because
for our fact table that fact data you
know that we expect it to be quite large
and we just won't have the ability to
replay the events or the transactions
for a given day and in the second use
case with the dimension data I mean even
if your dimension data is millions of
rows and if you think about that in
context of bigquery in these kind of
systems that you can use just replaying
that again and having a new snapshot
each day really helps you overcome from
those slowly changing dimension property
so yeah but different the partitioning
we're using there was basically on a
date which is the insertion date later
well available now is clustering in beta
so if you can imagine what costing
basically partition first on day and
then you'd have some other column with a
high cardinality which you basically
cluster on so again we're reducing the
amount of data that we need to pick up
in that initial scan which is going to
make the query
cheaper to run faster to run so if you
have good use cases this so think about
first of all you're joining or filtering
by day and then you're joining or
filtering by something else this would
be a good a good a good yeah as I say
feature to actually go and explore
something we didn't show here but data
studio Explorer it's basically from
going from bigquery and clicking and
actually being able to see the results
of that query directly in data studio
and there are deeper integrations with
sheets so just making the whole
experience using your data's in bigquery
available for end-users who are using
Google sheets and later this afternoon
free 15 if you're not coming to my
storage talk obviously then there's a
there's a nice talk about an GSI data as
well which is amazing some really great
ten months ago
there I'm really excited about that
actually I might just miss my own talk
and go and watch that fun so we've gone
through quite a lot today but what I
want to kind of hand it off is say so
we've gone through some of the reasons
why and and what we can do with this
we've gone through an approach how we
could do that first and mirroring and
then the full process running on GCP and
this last part is really kind of like
okay this is all great but you know how
do I organize myself together with
Google and together with partners to
actually go and do this migration so we
put together a playbook which we think
is kind of you know will help kind of
illustrate how to do this so these are
the different stages of the playbook so
first of all is documenting the current
state understanding exactly what it is
that you have the next thing is
outlining the experiment and we'll come
on to exactly why we do an experiment
getting resources lined up like you
can't do this by yourself
I mean you can it might just be one of
you and it's just your data warehouse
but typically there are many many people
involve stakeholders end-users other
teams so you know all those resources
need to be lined up how do we go about
committing and executing this and
importantly once we've gone through this
cycle showing the end users getting
everyone excited about the stuff and
then repeating it for the next bit I
guess you could call it some kind of
agile process now yeah I'm gonna go for
each of these stages now so document the
current state I go briefly through this
you know why we here like what are we
actually trying to accomplish like it's
we're not just migrating for the sake of
migrating there should be goals that we
have and we should be able to articulate
them where are we coming from you know
get the white board out get all the
people that are involved from the
different teams actually explaining
where you're coming from explain it to
us explain it to the partner as well
like if we understand where you're
coming from why you've made certain
decisions we can take those learnings
into the migration into the into the new
thing if we don't know about those
things and it's and we is all of us in
this case so the people that building
this to beat the partners all of us if
we
know about those things because you know
someone forgot to tell us then we're
gonna go and discover those later and
that will be you know somewhere down the
line after the migration or during the
migration when data doesn't look exactly
the same and then someone will say well
actually I decide to do it like this
before so it's really important to
understand that stuff and find out you
know get feedback from everyone involved
what's already working well nobody liked
you know having a new solution point in
place and it's saying hey this is great
but it works better over here you know
it's not the place you want to be and
what's not working well because this
will also help you already start to win
hearts and minds of people you say well
this piece isn't really working well so
if we maybe look explore some of that
you know we can already get some people
you know who are standing around the
water cooler you know talking about oh
great
we've actually solved this problem that
we had for a long time so outlining
experiment this is really kind of
digging into that piece of the
documentation and trying to understand
what it is what's the one piece we're
going to take from let's say for all the
possible things that we're going to go
into for this first one this next one
what is it we're trying to do so what's
possible what are the constraints why is
the value to the business
thinks like in the initial use cases as
I said this is an iteration but in those
initial use cases think about smaller
things you know get some experience I
know I just mentioned that there's this
problem that you want to solve but if
you can already get a quick win and just
get everyone's hands kind of accustomed
to what you're doing you know that next
bigger problems gonna already seem a lot
easier for exactly there are things that
you should be considering along the way
you should be asking us because an
example I once got handed a project
which was all of the add data and it was
a lot for the company I was working with
being imported on-premise because that's
how they did it they didn't have the
processing power on-premise so they
uploaded it into the cloud they ran a
Hadoop job on that data they then poured
it back and they put it into the data
warehouse with that time with sequel
server we were migrating to Vickery we
looked at this and we said hang on a
second you know like do we need to set
up this ETL process and there was a data
transfer
available which put the data straight
into bigquery now that's great if you're
working with do you know some GA data or
add data which is already available for
you in that in that way that data might
not be there but there are also as we
mentioned before partners that are
working on this data as well so if
you've got you know sources which other
people are using so our market data
Salesforce data all these things think
about you know how is other already
solutions out there for that that's just
you know keeping keeping everyone alert
making sure that we do useful things
define the time require the time frame
the requirements all this kinda stuff
and sketch out an architecture for the
experiment and try to make sure that
everyone is aligned I realize some of
this really speaks to itself but
sometimes just going through of every
one is really useful in like getting
everyone aligned lining up the resources
so there are a number of people involved
in this there's the customer there's a
partner there's Google and there are
others as well we may have analysts in a
specific domain we may have consultants
that you know I've done this before that
we're bringing in to work with us you
know it's really important to understand
who these people are what role they are
because another thing that we see that
happens is you know we start a migration
like oK we've got this team they're
going to do a migration and suddenly
there's this you know reason like for
example we don't have a partner in place
to actually help us and give us the
breath when we need or we don't have one
of the data experts in place and we
don't actually understand the stuff that
we're now migrating and we started the
migration and now we're like three weeks
and we've got a block and that person's
on holiday and now we have to wait and
you know it's fun and games so making
sure that we understand the resources in
it and who they are and getting them
lined up timely for this is really
important as well to be successful
commit and execute so there are some
things here you need to think about
security data locality the cost
licensing if you're you know there may
be some of the stuff you want to use the
party stuff from partners and you need
to bring your own license for example so
think about all these things and when
you're about to execute on this make
sure that anything that we execute on
addresses those concerns otherwise we're
good for another iteration we have one
kind of standing around saying hey but
the security doesn't live up to what I
was the security is going to be really
good but we need to make sure everyone
understands
the security's going to be really good
and had their chance to you know explore
that and get information about it and
the next thing you've just delivered an
MVP show everyone you know get everyone
excited let them see that it solves a
youth case and then you know get the
next one lined up and reiterate and just
keep doing this until everything's
migrated and you know you'll be happy
your end users would be happy and you
you'll be asking for new product
features on bigquery so that's it I'm
gonna leave you actually on this slide
which is some things for you to go and
get started check out try out these are
all small links so you can just go and
click on them there's about the data
journey there's GCP free there's some
architecture stuff there as well
[Music]